merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre coup politique suivi d'une
grande désinvolture sélection des
dossiers bâclés opaque précipitations
dans l'élaboration du cahier des charges
comme de l'appel à candidature fait du
prince concernant l'attribution ou la
nure ou la non attribution de
subventions et finalement un fiasco la
commission d'enquête sanatoriale sur le
fond Marianne sous l'égide de son
président Claude Raynal et de son
rapporteur Jean-François Husson a établi
un rapport accablant si ajoute les
conclusions de l'inspection générale de
l'administration tout aussi sévère les
dysfonctionnements constatés ils sont
d'autant plus graves qu'il concerne une
politique publique indispensable celle
de la lutte contre la propagande
islamiste et ce n'est pas cet objectif
qui doit être remis en cause c'est son
détournement qui est inacceptable et qui
doit être dénoncé alors madame la
ministre comptez-vous mettre en œuvre
les recommandations établies par la
commission d'enquête sénatoriales pour
éviter que de telles dérives ne se
reproduisent et surtout quelles
conséquences politiques le gouvernement
compte-t-il en tirer
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la secrétaire d'État chargée de
la citoyenneté madame Sonia baquet
j'avais la parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
sénatrices monsieur les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Ferro il me tient
un coeur d'abord que nous restions dans
cette affaire factuelle je veux d'abord
rappeler que le gouvernement a fait
preuve à la fois de réactivité et de
transparence dès les premières
interrogations dans ce dossier
réactivité avec la demande qui a été
faite à l'inspection générale de
l'administration dès les premières
alertes et le signalement sur le
fondement de l'article 40 à la procureur
de la République de Paris sur les mêmes
signalements transparence avec la
transmission et vous le savez bien
monsieur le sénateur au plus vite de
tous les documents qui ont été demandés
par la commission d'enquête du Sénat par
l'Inspection générale de
l'administration et désormais par le
parquet national financier qui a démarré
une enquête qu'il ne m'a pas qu'il ne
m'appartient pas de commenter désormais
il nous faut et vous l'avez dit tirer
les conséquences de ce qui s'est passé
sur ce dossier
uniquement grave qui ont été constatés à
la fois par la commission d'enquête du
Sénat et par la liaspection générale de
l'administration c'est fait sont
inacceptables et nous appartient
maintenant de mettre en oeuvre tout ce
qu'il faut pour sécuriser nos procédures
et donc de mettre en œuvre l'ensemble
des préconisations de l'inspection
générale de l'administration et les
recommandations de la commission
d'enquête du Sénat mais je veux aussi
dire qu'il nous appartient et vous
l'avez dit de sécuriser cette politique
publique cette politique publique de
lutte contre les séparatismes je
voudrais rappeler également que sur les
17 associations qui ont été lauréates du
fond Marianne 15 on fait un travail
absolument remarquable contre ceux qui
s'attaquent à nos valeurs contre ceux
qui considèrent que les lois de la
religion sont supérieures à celles de la
République et pour que ces associations
puissent continuer pour qu'elles
puissent continuer à nous accompagner
dans le combat nous devons les soutenir
et faire la part des choses entre les
manquements aussi graves soient-ils qui
ont été constatés et notre engagement
sur le sujet et je suis convaincue
pardon que vous le que vous le partagez
et que nous devons lutter ensemble
contre ces ennemis de la République je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre nous partageons les
objectifs de lutte contre la propagande
islamiste mais votre réponse n'est pas
convaincante vous parlez de réactivité
et de transparence mais quelles
conséquences politiques tirez-vous de
cette affaire après la révélation du
scandale du fond Marianne la première
ministre avait déjà jugé que se séparer
de la ministre concernée n'était je cite
pas nécessaire pourtant disons-le dans
n'importe quel autre pays européen
madame siapa aurait déjà démissionné du
gouvernement il y a eu dans cette
affaire beaucoup d'irresponsabilités il
est temps de faire prévaloir le principe
de responsabilité politique c'est une
exigence démocratique c'est une exigence
républicaine
[Musique]